all right charlie
charlie uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
i'm from new york city and i grew up in
astoria queens and long island new york
tell me about your family growing up i
had a few really good years uh my uh
focus came in about 1968 i was three
years old and my parents got me a puppy
german shepherd who we named ringo
and my dad had a really cool convertible
it's an impala
and
we had some good times growing up in
queens and we headed out to uh woodstock
in 1969
we didn't have tickets and my parents
didn't intend on getting in but they
just wanted to be part of the atmosphere
the festival and we picked up a really
cool hitchhiker along the way his name
was gary
and back then hitchhikers had his pots
and pans hanging from his daniel boone
type jacket
water bottles
and it was a really good time
my life took a sudden change after that
in 1969 my friend kenny
was the first reported death in new york
city
of a child overdosing on methadone
he had drank his uncle's methadone that
was in the refrigerator thinking it was
juice and his brain swelled and he went
to sleep and never woke up
and after that my life started to change
i started to realize
the happy go lucky inside me
felt as though
you could get hurt in your own apartment
building
[Music]
my parents also
changed their relationship changed after
that because we moved to long island
and my dad got a home out there and
happiness should have been the story but
it wasn't
my mother and father started really
having volatile fights
and there was drinking involved
and my dad would break up the house
and all this really robbed me
of kind of growing up and feeling the
way i should have felt prior to kenny
overdosing and my family fights
so from there things never got any nicer
my father who was a very violent man
i didn't know much about him even though
he was in my life
he started to do crazy things like i
wouldn't go in the pool that he had put
up and it frustrated him and he went
around with an old edger like they had
back in the 70s and went around the side
of the pool and hatcheted the liner and
all the water
came out of the pool 15 000 gallons of
water blew out the backyard
and my dog was
tied to a cinderblock ringo and
he went down the driveway with the water
he survived and
it just just really was a horrible time
growing up
you know my father
never really even gave us a heads up as
to where his anger came from
and
as time would go on
he was just brutal to live with
he was very hard on my mother and my
mother was a girl that grew up without a
mother and father her parents both had
died so she didn't know what her
childhood was and then she wound up
marrying my father
the earliest memory i have of being
thrown out of my house was i was eight
years old
my mother knew my father would go crazy
so she put my little denim jacket on me
and she told me to get out
and i got out of the house with no money
and no food
and i walked all the way to roosevelt
field out in long island that's where
charles lindbergh took off
and i spent the evening in
roosevelt field but i got tired and
walked home and the police were waiting
for me
and it was my first interaction with the
police
and they were like big brothers to me
they hugged me and they told me back
then somebody asked you for a dime and
if you don't have it they could beat you
up and if you do have it they could take
more money from you
so from there
my father who was in the concrete
business and he was in the union
trucking business
wound up moving to another part of long
island
which the home was bigger and we thought
maybe it would be a change in things
but it simply wasn't
we grew up in
merrick from there and although there
was a bigger house and more money
i started to get thrown out like a dash
dishrag all the time i got thrown out
again when i was 12 years old
it was horrible
no money no food
and i was sleeping in the parking lot of
an elementary school over the summer
and they had tunnels back then the kids
used to play in and i slept in the
tunnel as a little kid at 12 years old i
figured if i slept in the middle of the
tunnel
that if somebody came in from one end to
the other end i could leave
and the way i would eat was
the police department would come at
night time and the cars would go driver
to driver with the windows
meeting each other and they would have
their conversation if they got a call
they would throw their food out the
window
and i would go behind and scurry the
food and pick it up and get whatever i
could
and then i'd go to the supermarket in
the morning
and get the loaves of bread and break
the bread off
and i never
ever felt
i was living i was always in survival
mode and that went on when i was 12 and
it went on when i was 13.
and i finally would leave my house at 17
years old i couldn't take it anymore and
my life
took a direction
that
i never intended it to i wanted to have
this life that i was happy
joyous and free and at 17 i was already
out of my parents house working at the
nightclubs
and i was
bouncing at the bars
and i picked up an addiction
because i started to drink
and i started to use pills
and before i knew it
i was addicted
i had back problems that created some of
the problems but when i took that first
drug
my life had changed
because i went from being in survival
mode to feeling confident the feeling as
though
i was okay
and
i don't even
think about my childhood as being a
childhood
it was just an obstacle course of trying
to survive
now through all this
i never really ventured into my father's
life all i knew is that he worked for a
concrete company
he was involved with it he was involved
in a union trucking
so from there
i wound up
heading out to where my father's
concrete plant was and that was in the
infamous part of brooklyn east new york
the 75th precinct patrols that area
and drugs are rampant out there
and i picked that place to go because i
had known it from my father's days of me
growing up there
going to work with him from time to time
and i knew the drugs were there
and i
wound up
at 22 years old
addicted to drugs addicted to heroin
i was sniffing heroin
i was
popping all kinds of pills
i was living my life
in a way that i couldn't even believe it
like a third person i was like outside
myself and i couldn't believe this was
going on but it was
and there was a lot of pain going on at
that time
and i've always
really kind of been an outlier i've kind
of always hung out with myself
and through my time in east new york
i wound up
on the drug that i
couldn't believe killed my friend i
wound up drinking methadone because i
found as though in between highs that
could keep me going
and
i wound up addicted to that i wound up
addicted to pills i went up addicted to
dope
and
my life was really going down the drain
and i needed an intervention
i had tried a few detoxes but they
didn't work
i simply could not understand how to get
out of this addiction
what happened was
addiction takes a life of its own i
think early on you do the drugs and you
kind of say wow i did the drug it's no
big deal then you do some more
then you try to walk away from the drug
and the drug kind of grabs you from the
collar and says ah you're not leaving me
we got a relationship
it's me and you buddy
it's me and you it's a cozy relationship
the drugs talk to you
they make you believe that everything's
going to be okay they're the best
confidence man in the world
and here i am
i come from an abusive house
i'm abusing myself
and i'm hooked on dope
but i have a vision that i'm going to
get out of this one day but rehabs
detoxes are not working i keep on trying
them
as my life is going on in this descent
i've met people good bad and different
i met a cop one time
in my grade school that wound up
becoming
a really cool guy he wound up going on
and moving up in the police department
and new york city police department
and
he would give me some direction at some
time that i'd come back to
but
the problem with drugs is that this
happens you think you can manage it and
it wants to be fed and there's times
when it gives you a reprieve to make you
think hey i got this
one of those times was
i got a soda delivery route so happened
to be right in east new york
i was delivering cheap soda
in the worst parts of neighborhoods that
you wouldn't want to be found dead in
and inside this soda delivery route
i found someone that wanted to get rid
of a dog
and i showed interest in the dog i could
have got the dog for nothing but once i
showed interest they wanted 70 dollars
and i bought the dog
and i didn't know how much of a pivotal
change as this dog would have in my life
but i'm still talking about it now
1988's a long time ago
i put this dog in my truck and we
deliver soda together every day
until
the drugs finally
take me out
i can't put gasoline in my truck anymore
i can't work anymore i'm disabled from
the drugs all i want to do is drugs
i'm living in my apartment in long
island with a dog
no money no food
and i finally get to a point in my life
where my mind is so clouded from the
drugs
prior when i had some drugs in me i
could ask
someone for
food i could con my way into getting
something or taking a loaf of bread i
got so disabled from the drugs that i
had no way of providing food for me or
my dog
it got down to one
bottle of salad dressing in my house
that was all that was left
i would take a squirt i'd give my dog a
squirt
and i'm living this life
of total total
segregation i go from 200 and somewhat
pounds to 167.
but
my mother decides to send my father
looking for me which is a very odd act
in its own because that's something my
father would never do
he came he knocked on the door i thought
the police were at the door
i go to the front door and it's my
father and my father was built like an
mma fighter 175 pounds and this guy
could fight
and he was in my face
and he says look at you what have you
done with your life
and i ran away from him
and i ran across a four-lane
highway to get away from him
and my dog followed me
and my dog got hit by two cars
boom i turn around
the dog gets up boom gets hit again
i turn around
my father runs into the highway i run
into the highway
my dog i thought was dead
my father takes his car and he spins it
around and puts it on the highway two
guys that can never get along
put my dog in the car
and we took him to an emergency vet
and he lived
he lived
but i was over a barrel
my parents said you got no money we
don't care about your life but you're
not gonna take this dog down with you so
he showed some humanists
and i took my dog
and from there
i
had no place nothing to do
and i got on the train
just to kind of clear my head
and was gonna happen here was i was
gonna meet that cop that i met in high
school
and he would see me on this jamaican
platform
and he'd look at me and he knew i was
killing myself with the drugs and he
gave me a look that i had to think to
myself this is not going good
but i still wanted to do drugs i still
wanted to go back to east new york i
still wanted to numb myself out with
these drugs
and what happened was
this peaceful looking guy named michael
there'll be a turning point in my life
he would appear
and he'd look at me and i'd look at him
and i'd say to myself boy that's a
really peaceful looking guy and he come
over to me and he'd introduce himself
and he told me
that he was living in a refrigerator box
in the bronx that he too was addicted
and he found a spiritual
reprieve
in a monastery in upstate new york
called
graymore
and i said to him do you usually tell
people this he says no
but you look hurting you look like
you're really hurting i said to him in a
quick rundown of my life i said detox is
not working
nothing's working
i said do i look bad he says you got
tombstones in your eyes i said where i
live
he says if you don't get
this arrested this addiction you won't
make it
but i still didn't take that and the cop
that i knew from high school
as enough i got on the train
and i rode the train to try to figure
out what i was going to do with my life
that my dog is gone
my life is gone
i wasn't paying my rent and my apartment
i was being evicted i had no
transportation
i would decide to get off this
train
in the middle of the night
and get off at east new york and start
walking around
and i would be on a search for drugs
which was by itself insane
i come across a burnt out building
and there's men with a 50-gallon drum
keeping warm and shooting up drugs
and what happened
was i felt a push to go towards them to
ask them if i could use drugs with them
a chanting in me
go ask if you could join them go ask if
you could join them now i hadn't shot up
drugs
i was drinking methadone popping pills
and sniffing dope
i had this desire to destroy myself and
i couldn't stop it
i had no willpower
but i thought about that guy michael on
the train station i thought about his
belief with the spiritual and i believed
because he believed and i started
chanting god help me god help me god
help me
all of a sudden it gave me strength it
gave me
power it made the stop forward motion
stop and i yelled out god help me
and from there
the guys that were doing drugs by the 50
gallon drum they look up
they were startled
and i
turned around
and i'm not a runner
i ran as hard as i could
as long as i could and i finally get
to a fire station with the door open the
fdny
had a man a fireman he was doing
something with the truck and i run in
and i said i need help he goes what
happened where's the emergency i said
you're looking at it it's me
he says what's wrong i said i need water
i need water
i need to know
that i'm okay
no here's some water i washed my face i
looked at my face in the in the mirror i
couldn't believe what had happened to me
but i was awake
i was awake i realized that i was awake
and i did not want to continue this
lifestyle
so
i had no footwear
i had no footwear on my feet because
prior to this i was walking around those
cheap flip-flops the kind you get from a
hospital if you're if you're being
intake or the kind that you get at a
dollar store i'd know if it was barefoot
he gave me some sneakers he gave me a
shirt
and i got some money to get to the
jamaica train station where i would call
my father
and i called my father
at six o'clock in the morning
and he answered the phone like he
normally would hello i said dad i need
help
where are you i summit did you make a
train station
he says to me what are you doing there
i said i need a ride dad he goes it's
friday i got to work today
dad can give me a ride after work i can
he says where you going i said i got to
go up to graymore
he goes greymoy i go you know the place
he goes yeah it's been around forever he
goes that's for people that are at the
end of the rope i said well i'm at the
end of my rope he says
i said it's perfect i need to be there
he says look i don't know why you want
to go there but i'll give you my word
i'll get off work and pick you up stay
in front of the jamaica's train station
don't leave back then there was no cell
phones
so
i stayed at the jamaica train station he
didn't get there till about almost seven
and he picks me up
there was a different energy flowing
between me and my father
my father who i'll get into in a second
why we can never get along
i get this car
and there's tension at first
but there's a different energy and he
says to me
son what's going on
i said dad you'll never understand what
happened i said almost died in brooklyn
tonight
how's how's my dog and that kind of gave
him a good mood he goes you know i don't
know what that dog is made of but the
dog is doing okay
the dog is doing okay i said great dad
and we drove up to graymore
and as luck would have it it was a rainy
night
and my father who like frank sinatra
pavarotti he had cassettes of the of the
time hooting the blowfish aaron neville
was playing
and two guys like i talked earlier in
this
that could never get along we rode in
peace till i got up to graymore
went to graymore
my father showed me the first emotion in
his whole life towards me he got a
little teary-eyed he goes son you sure
you want to do this i said i have to
so what occurred was
i went to graymore
and i got this what they call a
spiritual awakening
i was able
to understand what had happened i had
rowed down the road of addiction
but addiction is cunning
after about two weeks putting some
weight on
i told the monastery that i was ready to
go home they said oh you are
they said you're homeless you have no
home
your father said you don't have a home
you have no place to go we're providing
a home for you we're providing meals for
you
we're helping you
i started to cry
i spent some time at the monastery
i would go on to
go to rehab for a short period after
that and this time it worked
and i would get clean off of drugs and
alcohol and stay that way
then
at some point
after getting clean and sober the one
suggestion i tell you is in the first
year of sobriety
don't get in a relationship
i got in a relationship
i met a girl
outside the rehab
and it changed my life the girl happened
to have family in nebraska
i got serious with the girl
after about a week i got a u-haul truck
and we moved in no
we got i got serious and we wound up
starting a life together
the life
that started in new york wound up in
nebraska so here i'm in this new
relationship i wind up getting married
the only place that would hire me
of all places was the department of
corrections
so here i am with this past but i'm
clean
they run my record
and although i had some jam-ups nothing
was substantial that didn't get
dismissed
or move on because again it's new york
maybe if it was missouri or other places
they would have given me a record
and i get a job for the department of
corrections
and i start to live my life as if
nothing would have happened
the problem with this was
wherever you take yourself
if you're wounded you're going to feel
your feelings
probably the last place i needed to work
as a department of corrections so i went
from the streets of new york the drugs
to a monastery
and within
a year's time
i graduate the academy for the
department of corrections
and i'm in between death row inmates and
their visitors
i have serial killers
their families visiting them and in
nebraska is different than other states
nebraska
although the prison system is a pretty
intense prison system and doesn't make
the news a lot for overcrowding and a
lot of violence they believe visits
should be with no glass
so i did the visits
and
a lot of things occurred with those
visits
a lot of hair on the back of my neck
stood up
and i went from
one extreme to the other extreme
and i would be there
right down to the wire with these death
row inmates and i asked them questions
there's always been a question asking
guy
hey
if you had your life to do again what
would you do different they all said
life takes care of itself if i didn't
introduce myself into a situation or i
didn't use anger or drugs or alcohol i
would have not been here
but i had to have my desired result i
had to take justice in my own hands
you know unlike what people hear in the
movies prison's a lot different
not everybody is charlie manson not
everybody is in there for being a serial
killer although the death row inmates
usually are people that have gone to
that extreme
but a lot have killed one person
a lot have had a bad day where
they took out their aggression and now
they got the death penalty the death
penalty is not given to everyone and
there are situations where somebody may
have murdered three people and don't get
the death penalty and somebody murders
one person and gets the death penalty
i'm here now hearing all this
but i'm clean and sober now
and i'm living my life
and from this position
i'm going to learn one more valuable
lesson that is going to put me on the
new path that i've been on
today is
my 24th year of continuous sobriety
in 1998
working death row
i decided that alcohol wasn't a drug and
i decided to drink
it was a short relapse
i quickly got paranoid from alcohol the
brain didn't know what it was being
anesthetized by all it knew was being
numbed and then i'd come too again then
i get numb didn't come too
paranoia
night sweats
everything the drugs did the alcohol did
so what occurred was
in 1998
i was working in the department of
corrections
and paranoia hit me
i got spooked
i didn't know where i was
i look around
and there's all these cops with uniforms
on
i'm like where the [ __ ] am i how did i
get here now here's the crazy part
i was sober i hadn't drank that day i
drank the night before
but paranoia
fear set in
i looked down and i'm wearing a badge
i'm part of the system
i don't know how i got into this
i leave that day
i have a drink
to calm my nerves
and that will be the last drink
that i ever have now here is what a lot
of addicts and alcoholics say is you
can't project the future
i made a decision right then and there
that drugs and alcohol are no part of my
life
my co-workers knew i was off i hadn't
got written up yet it was coming
but what's different i had a problem
with alcohol i had co-workers that
walked out in the parking lot went home
and shot themselves in the head i had
co-workers that
drank themselves to death i had a form
of what i was seeing
i get sober and within 30 days my life
changes
i wind up moving up in the department of
corrections i wind up becoming a
caseworker
i wind up getting other promotions
i went to becoming the first
correctional officer in uniform to
testify as a character witness for a
death row inmate did i ask to do that no
but the inmate had said to himself that
he's following the rules that he's
following the mission statement that
he's doing everything he's supposed to
do and he wants to be resentenced
i from that point on went and told the
truth
with the inmate not that i told didn't
tell the truth prior to that but i told
them exactly what they wanted to hear
which was the truth
his defense attorney asked me the
prosecutor asked me
and that was that i moved through
corrections
about the 10-year point i had the keys
to the whole institution at the nebraska
penitentiary
and
i wind up saying to myself this isn't my
future i don't want this this is not
what i want to do with my life
when i decide to leave corrections they
were shocked
i only had two supervisors the associate
award and wharton
the warden
and the associate warden were shocked
that i was leaving because i had
overcome so much
i was clean and sober and really living
a good life i started the trash business
somewhere along the line towards my
eighth or ninth year in corrections it
had taken off
i felt as though that i missed a lot of
things in my childhood
this trash business really grew and grew
and grew
and i quickly found that even money
could not fix the hole inside me
whatever i thought was going to fix me
the cars the right home
the girlfriend
it didn't
i'm going to take you to a further point
in my life
in 2012
i was at my desk in the trash business
and we've gone from 1988
through the 90s
through the new millennial
i left corrections
i turned in my notice the wednesday
after 9 11 that was the changing point
of my life
i said nope i'm going to stick with my
business i'm going to stick with my
goals
and i did it
on august
12th august 13 2012.
i i'm sitting at my desk in nebraska and
i look at the new york daily news
and headlines will change my life it'll
give me the life that i have right today
it'll say
bull
shot and killed homeless man's pit bull
shot and killed
i didn't know why
that headline meant so much to me
it would take years till i really knew
what that meant you see i really cleaned
myself up
i
got myself fit
i really removed myself from any past of
really hanging out in east new york
having the childhood i had
and i had moved past all that i was a
businessman now i was sitting at my desk
but when that door got shot
something in my stomach just flipped
upside down i couldn't handle it i
called in anybody i could in my office i
called the vice president of the company
i had to look at the video that the
daily news had put up
he said charlie it's a sad story the
homeless man had a seizure
and they shot his dog because they
wanted to offer help to the dog and the
dog was circling the man
i couldn't accept that for some reason
here's what i believed in my life
i believed because i've always been in
survival mode if you put the drugs in my
hand
as i put the money in your hand
we're square
if i deliver a dumpster my company
delivers a dumpster and you put a check
or cash in my driver's hand we're good
i had no faith
but for some reason that day
i had tremendous amount of faith
and i believed that that dog had lived
and i called the city of new york
and i didn't lie
and i called them from my business line
and they saw that it was a recycling
trash business
i called up and asked for the admin of
the dog
shelter that handled all of new york
city's dog problems
and i got a lady renee on the phone who
said
to me after we talked about recycling
and trash and i warmed her up a little
bit
the dog is actually still alive
the dog
will probably die but the public can
handle a dog
that is dead rather than one that's
lingering
and that's why they put that out
i had purpose for the first time in my
life
for the first time in my life
i decided to put all my energy into
something rather than be in survival
mode
fear went away i gotta save this dog's
life i gotta find this dog
now the story went global because the
daily news the new york city police said
dog is dead dog is dead i started the
facebook page star of the new york pit
bull that was the only way i knew how to
communicate with people and i put
my thoughts of this dog
to the public
and it took a lightning speed change the
public rallied behind me
and this dog the daily news had to go
from
dog is dead the dog is making a
lightning speed recovery the dog is in
wikipedia star of the dog
the dog is global they everywhere put
the dog nebraska man this that
so the city of new york kind of had a
black eye that the dog was dead then
came back alive and they stuck the dog
in philadelphia under an assumed name
and all this stuff occurred
and while this was going on
and i was building a big audience
i decided that there would be no other
goal in my life but to find this dog and
to give this dog a home
and i walked away from the trash
business and i walked away from
everything that had me connected
that was
about me surviving about me paying bills
about this about that
i was on a quest and i didn't know it at
the time
to reclaim my life
and to get a childhood again
i had a california filmmaker say to me
charlie i've read all these headlines
man you don't get it
the reason why you have done this
because that homeless man and that dog
was you that was you on the ground that
was you that nobody cared about that was
you that was addicted that was you you
you and that dog
that was your dog
that you couldn't give a good homewood
because the addiction robbed you of that
this dog would be different
i rescued that dog
with all the fervor i had
they put the dog in philadelphia they
gave her a new name they did all this
i wind up eventually convincing the city
of new york to make me the lawful owner
of this dog
and i get this dog
and me and this dog
do some really wonderful things for
others
we get involved in the alzheimer's
association we do walks we do cancer
walks
we
start a a dog rescue and rescue dogs
and all this stuff comes about and at
some point
in 2018
several years the dog i wound up giving
a home to the dog in 2013 she was shot
in 2012. i decided to write a book
about this story
and i went to newspapers.com and punched
in my name my father's name and my last
name to see if i can give any background
about my father i didn't know much about
and to my
complete i wouldn't believe what i would
see
i thought maybe you know
this or that my father is involved with
a man that i believed was my godfather
josephine briglia
who's involved in a french connection
who the fbi is looking for in 1980 for a
hundred million dollar synthetic heroin
ring who in 1956
sticks up a cabaret with my dad
and the cops show up at new york city
police and they put a gun in his stomach
and the gun misfires that gun didn't
miss fire
i'd never be here
my father goes away
and now the picture gets clear
he's a dangerous man
this guy never had bedside manner
he went away at 24 years old to
dannemora clinton one of the worst
prisons
this man that i didn't know
had this crazy crazy background
so i continued writing my book
and in 2018
which i was writing it i go back up to
graymore 25 years after i left with my
dog star they said
you can come
under one stipulation you must bring
this miracle dog we've read about her
and imagine going back to the place that
saved my life with my dog
and not only did they want her there
they cherished her there
she ate off the same plates as we did
we talked to the board of directors and
i told him about my life since i had
gone there
we had met the staff we had met the
residents and i told them my story how i
had to overcome addiction
and my new life
well
i had this information about my father
and when i went to the monastery
they said to me that i had to forgive
him
he didn't do the best he could
but he's a human you've been forgiven
it took me a few days to compose myself
when i got back in 2018
i knew i had to tell him it wasn't for
him i got i would never got up to that
cramer in the first place and he did
answer my call
my mother was upset and she text
messaged me
that he unexpectedly went to the
hospital because of heat exhaustion
and they mistakenly gave him a deadly
dose of fentanyl and he died
so i spent a lot of time being angry at
him
and then when i get the solution
he's now gone
he's gone
i got to continue my life
i go forward
i continue to go forward with my dog
i wind up meeting that police officer
that many years earlier
that looked at me at that train station
and i get friendly with him again
and he becomes a source of strength
and 2019 happens in 2020 as we know with
the pandemic
2020
it's a blur
clean and sober
2021 happens
and my dog gets sick
star gets sick
and i bring it to the vet and they don't
think anything's major wrong with her
but she's got some edema
she's got some swelling they don't know
they aspirate her lump it's not cancer
then they think it might be cancer
and she's laying down on the couch and
won't get up
and i'm getting everybody telling me
it's her time it's time for her to go
well
i don't want to make that decision but
it looks like i may have to
she gets off the couch
she gets off the couch
like nothing happened
this dog that came back from the dead
that is now
off the couch
what do i do with her
what do i do
i decide to take her back where her life
started
she grew up on the streets of the lower
the not the lowest side the east village
i bring it back to the east village
people see her
hey star i know her
i see her on facebook
we have a tremendous day
because i'm around people you know
the people that make me feel comfortable
are the people that have something
called time
who has time in america
people that don't have a an agenda
homeless people
travelers
people that aren't
bought into a success quota like i
thought like i thought i was going to
get happy successful get a home
i didn't even recognize the home i was
in it was sterile
that didn't make me happy i went to the
east village it made me happy with my
dog
and we enjoyed that day and we enjoyed
going to freedom tower and i got all
these photos
i had a few maybe it was a month of good
life with her
and then on february 19th 2021
with my fiance next to me i said you
know what i'm going to give star a bath
i'm going to give her a bath
she's health is going back and forth but
she's doing okay today
and i pick her up to give her a bath to
bring her to the bathtub
and she takes in about three deep
breaths
i put her down
and she's dead
there's a dog that gave me a childhood
this dog that gave me everything gave me
purpose was just gone there was no hey
listen
you're at the vet you might have another
day or two she was just gone she died i
couldn't i couldn't even believe she was
just dead gone
i know what to do with myself
i know to do it myself
there is a place you could be in
when you don't use drugs and alcohol
there's a place you could be in when you
don't do behaviors that are destructive
there's a place you can be in when you
don't decide to overeat anymore it's
called feeling
and i wasn't given a lot of emotional
muscle from the factory
and now i was feeling like i never felt
before and i wanted the pain to stop
i could not believe this beautiful dog
that just left the planet i couldn't
believe it
so she was gone
and
i asked my fiance i said please
take a picture of me with this dog
take a picture i didn't have a chance to
take one last picture she goes honey she
looks distorted from whatever happened
to her whether she had a heart attack
whether she had a aneurysm
i said no i'm going to the living room
i'm going to take a picture with my dog
and i took the dog probably 20 minutes
after she passed away and i sat on the
couch
and air came out of her lungs and
something happened
and a smile came to her face
and i got that picture
that's my picture
she might be a public dog she might be
known all over the world but that is my
dog that is my dog
and i had been through all these
situations in this life i've been
through taking the last cup of coffee
from a death row inmate
i've been through situations with death
row inmates telling me stuff that no
human should ever hear
and we are the unsung heroes in law
enforcement that the work in corrections
there's stuff that happens to us and we
see stuff that no human soul should ever
see
because there's no privacy in prison
and i take this picture
and i decide that
i don't know what to do
but i remember the filmmaker that told
me that i was that homeless man in this
story
and i was that
that dog was my dog
and although
people always ask what happened to the
homeless man
him like me was almost exactly like a
mirror
he decided to take care of his addiction
to seizures he couldn't handle the dog
so he signed the dog over to the city of
new york just like i signed my dog over
to my parents i'd have to sign it they
took it
so what happens now
is i think about with that filmmaker
charlie makes something good out of
something bad
charlie you got to make something good
out of something bad
and i didn't think there'd be a life
after star
the thought of me giving an interview
the thought of me going and talking to
anybody after this
it'd be very selfish
there are people that are listening to
this that think their life might be over
they think they've made the biggest mess
of their lives and there's no hope
there is hope
there is hope
there is hope when we stop using there
is hope when we get a solution
and for me
the ability that people take their time
and listen and give me an opportunity to
tell my story
i know there's no shortage of people
that have had a bad childhood i know
there's no shortage of people that want
to talk about themselves
but for me
it's been a lifesaver to be able to talk
about my journey with star
and talk about this incredible dog
i lived
in reverse
i should have grew up and matured and
got emotional muscle and went on to have
a life
no
i had a dog
that gave me a childhood that taught me
about human beings and relationships see
she was more of a human being than she
was a dog
taught me that i'm a human being not a
human doing
taught me that although i'm a citizen
of the united states i'm really a
citizen of the world
this dog taught me that my friends are
global
that when i hear the news because it
doesn't happen from california to maine
doesn't mean it didn't happen
i care
all over and somebody like myself i
can't harbor resentments it's a death of
me because i need sunlight and i've been
given a pass
for a second chance and i believe
everybody deserves a second chance
beautiful talk show charlie thank you
you